hey 42 here when was the last time you
gave to charity
maybe you popped your change into the
collection bucket at your local store
perhaps you give a few quid monthly via
one or more subscriptions to your
favorite charities
maybe you got bullied by some bloke in
the streets he was armed with a
clipboard and a fake smile into
subscribing to some Bazaar charity that
gives out eye patches to one-eyed
pheasants and you've regretted it ever
since
you just can't stomach the guilt of
canceling your Direct Debit don't worry
we've all been there
now let me ask you when you gave to
charity how did it make you feel I'm
willing to bet you felt pretty damn good
about yourself in one study that
involved brain MRIs it was found that
when we voluntarily make donations a
part of the brain called the ventral
striatum lit up this is the reward
center of the brain and it also lights
up when people do cocaine in other words
giving to charity is a highly hedonistic
pursuit the researchers behind this
story refer to the feeling when people
made donations as a warm glow people
know that when they give a fiver to a
dog shelter they will get a warm glow
that's why they do it it has very little
to do with the dogs themselves yes I am
insinuating that giving to charity is a
selfish act we do it because it makes us
feel good not because it actually does
God and I can prove it about 10% of
people will give money at every
opportunity 10% will never give and the
remaining 80% will give if the
opportunity in front of them talks it
just to write heartstrings of emotional
guilt but it's not actually the guilt
that makes the people give it's the fact
that they know they will feel better
about themselves afterwards they will
feel lot warm glow a study published in
the Journal of Neuroscience found that
most people in that 80% brackets only
give when they think their donation will
put a smile on us
cific person's face not many people's
faces but one specific individual who
they can envision smiling because the
brains pleasure centers are activated
when we make others smile and ultimately
that is what the donor is seeking that's
feeling of self gratification the study
found that people are less likely to
give when confronted with statistics
over the plight of an individual for
instance if a bunch of people were shown
a TV ad that explains how contaminated
drinking water causes the deaths of half
a million Africans each year according
to the research these people are very
unlikely to give money to help fix that
however if those same people are shown
the story of young malnourished Timmy
who treks 3 miles barefoot every day to
collect dirty water for his family a
large number of those people would
donate money because they can envision
their donation putting a smile on the
face of Timmy
whereas helping out half a million
people well it feels cold empty it
doesn't activate the same pleasure
responses in the brain in fact it goes
even further because studies have found
that when the scale of a disaster or
need is represented with numbers it
actually lowers the chance that people
will donate whereas presenting a single
sad story of unand 'visible whilst
hiding the actual statistics and data
vastly increases giving multiple studies
have also highlighted the importance of
face-to-face interaction during the
giving process and how that heavily
affects the amounts donated it has been
generally found that people will donate
significantly more when they are doing
it for a friendly intermediary and they
can see the faces of the people they are
helping either in images or in real life
not to mention the smile that they will
put on the face of the intermediary the
charity worker whether it's fake or not
to further prove my point that donations
are often
selfishly motivated one of the richest
Charities in the UK is a donkey
sanctuary in Devon it typically receives
14 million pounds each year don't get me
wrong
donkeys are important but I am sure if
you asked most people overall what
matters more curing cancer or caring for
sick or injured donkeys they would
answer cancer yet when it comes down to
handing over their money people usually
opt for a donkey sanctuary over a cancer
research charity because unfortunately
there's nothing glamorous about cancer
but donkeys well they're just a bundle
of joy children can go pet them and they
just look so darn good on posters people
ultimately choose to donkey sanctuary
because giving - donkey gives them that
warm fuzzy glow if you want to find the
best place to see self-gratification
motivating charitable giving in action
then look no further than Facebook back
in 2017 Facebook introduced a new
feature the ability to donate your
birthday to a charity or cause of your
choosing and then on that day Facebook
will aggressively bombard all your
virtual friends with a guilt trip
reminder to donate to that charity
because Sandra from that place you used
to work at from a week last summer has
donated her birthday to it on the
surface this whole practice seems like a
purely altruistic thing to do but I
would argue that donating your birthday
to a charity of a social media platform
is possibly the most self-aggrandizing
way to give money and this is why
Facebook is a platform that was intended
to connect the world but the reality is
that it's made the world more
disconnected than ever before because
people don't log on to Facebook to
socialize they log on to get
self-gratification I won't go into yet
another round about Facebook you can go
and read a bunch of studies about the
damaging psychology of the platform
if you
desire but generally people logon
primarily to see how many likes their
latest post has amassed and analyze
exactly who and who has not likes it and
what better way is there to get likes
and mass adornment from your social
circle by telling them all how
wouldn't've ly altruistic you are by
donating your birthday and there may be
another reason why most people enjoy
giving according to a study from 2005
donating money and other forms of giving
is something that has been hardwired
into our DNA through evolution because
as it turns out it may be good for your
health
a study in 1999 followed over 55 s for a
five-year period it was found that those
who regularly volunteered their time
and/or money were significantly more
likely to still be alive at the end of
those 5 years than those who never
helped or gave to of us this could
possibly be because more recent studies
have found that giving significantly
reduces blood pressure such as a very
recent study carried out by the
university of british columbia that gave
128 adults between 65 to 85 40 dollars
each week for 3 weeks half were told to
spend the money on themselves the other
half were instructed suspended on others
those who spent their money on others
saw a noticeable drop in stress levels
and blood pressure after only three
weeks there was no change in blood
pressure levels for the participants who
spent the money on themselves
furthermore it was found that the
largest blood pressure level decreases
were seen when people chose to give
their money to people close to them or
causes that were close to their heart
for example a war veteran would see
greater health benefits by giving to a
PTSD related charity rather than a cat
sanctuary probably the most selfish
realm of philanthropy is when its
carried out by high net worth
individuals as an attempt at showing the
world how ostensibly virtuous
they are celebrities and charity go
together like cheese and wine bono
Angelina
Clooney Oprah the list is endless
despite the fact that charities all over
the world continue to hire celebrity
brand ambassadors in their droves the
research indicates that it actually are
horrendously ineffective form of
marketing and a huge waste of the
charity in questions donation funds
research conducted in the UK at the
universities of Manchester and Sussex
indicates that celebrities are
ineffective at motivating people to
support charities the research indicated
that whilst people can easily associate
certain celebrities with philanthropy
they struggle to remember which
charities and causes those celebrities
have promoted so the net brand exposure
for those charities is actually rather
limited however the vastly increased PR
exposure for the celebrity is enormous
because even when virtue signaling is
obvious and transparent it still wins
people over it also found that people
are very rarely influenced by celebrity
endorsements to support a certain
charity and that they are much more
likely to choose charities based on
personal connections such as those that
target issues which may affect them or a
member of their family so then it turns
out that giving isn't only motivated by
pure altruism giving to charity is for
the most part a selfish act but you know
what that's absolutely fine that's we
live in a society where a large number
of us regularly give money to those who
need it the most is a wonderful thing
and does it really matter if the motives
for that are self-serving no of course
it doesn't
charity recipients don't care why people
give they are just grateful that people
do so long as people are giving wisely
to the correct charities as I've covered
in a previous video so by my estimation
if the only reason that most people
donate is to make themselves feel better
then that's fantastic because the end
result is that people do donate after
all it's very likely that if giving to
charity didn't give us all a warm glow
then a significantly smaller number of
us would ever do so sometimes
selfishness is the greatest motivator
for achieving greatness and doing great
things and there's absolutely nothing
wrong with that thanks for watching I've
recently launched my first book it's
called sticky flag in it a thousand
years of bizarre history from Britain
and beyond if you want to get your hands
on a first edition signed copy then head
on over to unbound publishing the links
in the description and pledge today
thank you